all right celebrate if you didn't get
tagged
plenty of guys were not tagged on
on tuesday and we thought there was a
chance they would be only two receivers
tagged
kenny goliday was the biggest surprise
of guys
who were not tagged we didn't expect you
juice miss shoes to be tagged in
pittsburgh
other guys on this list we really didn't
have them on the radar screen
gallaudet is the one that the indication
seemed to be the lions were going to tag
him we had dan campbell the coach of the
team talking last week that it's
actually a good thing to be tagged even
though it's not
so gallaudet not tagged he didn't play
much last year chris and this is
something shereen williams and i were
kicking around last night
i can't help but wonder whether his
frustration with not
getting a long-term deal last year
before the season started
contributed to his willingness or lack
thereof to play with a tweaked hamstring
the old hold in and i'm not passing
judgment here it happens from time to
time
where a guy isn't willing to go out
there and take risks with his body
when he's yet to get his financial
security that's right no that's a real
aspect i mean of course
what do you expect i mean what what what
do people expect do they think that's
really fair to that guy
again he's his own business so
his business is being able to play
football and if he can't play it
you know towards the 100 level
let alone he's got not getting the
financial security
to go okay i'll risk it it's all right
the team's invested in me and
and i'll go out there and do what i got
to do you know we saw that over this
past year that team
that emboldened players to do that you
know whether it was dalvin cook or alvin
kamara okay you paid me
i'll play i'm not a hundred percent
whatever it is get it done
yeah i've talked about that story with
brandon brandon marshall many
times right i'm in the locker room in
philadelphia
and he's a psycho of course because he
wants to play and beat dbs up and run
over
safeties and doing all that and he's
frustrated we're sitting there looking
at
our each other's uniforms in the mirror
getting ready just to go out here
and he just looks at me and he yells ah
and i'm like what what's up dude and
it's i i can't do this
i can't i can't play like this i can't
lay it all on the line when i'm
two games away from being a free agent
and setting up my family
and it's not in the nfl players dna to
want to do that
but this is the way the rules are
business is business and kenny gallaudet
i'm sure that was part of
you know the issue but i'm still shocked
he didn't get tagged i'm shocked
marvin jones free agent you know there's
not really any receiver on that roster
that you look at and go
okay he's special he's got a chance um
i thought they would keep him especially
since they got jared goff
and they might want to you know they
want to make that work and make him look
good so
i'll be interested to see where this
goes and if they can get a deal done
with
kenny galladay plenty of great receivers
in the draft but it's a ton of work that
needs to be done to get these guys ready
to go and just because
you saw justin jefferson last year do
great right out of the gates and we saw
other guys
lower level guys like gabriel davis and
buffalo do great yeah that doesn't mean
you're going to bat a thousand with
something like that you're taking a
chance by having a rookie instead of a
veteran
and with with gallaudet he had 1190
receiving yards in 2019
pro bowler started all games 116
receptions
11 touchdowns last year he played in
five games with
20 catches he had 65 catches i'm looking
at his target 65 catches in
2019 still a pro bowler with 190 yards
20 catches last year for 338 and uh now
he hits the open market and the question
is do other teams
who understand how this works understand
that the production was down last year
because the playing time was down and
the playing time was down because he
wasn't comfortable
going forward with uh the contract year
and not getting the contract reward and
uh if people
get that then he'll still get a
significant contract on the open market
well
the the what jumps out to me there at
least like if i was gonna you know read
between the tea leaves right
with a good simsism there the fact that
they didn't franchise tag him
uh that makes me believe that
they're kind of going into a semi full
overhaul right like it's a new it's a
new coach
you know we got the new quarterback and
we're we're changing over this football
team
we're flipping it over all together and
we'll get all new pieces and do that
right i mean that's at least what it
seems like to me from the outside
looking in right now
it's it's the kneecap biter mentality
now
we have fun with that dan campbell quote
that he wants guys who's going to bite
one
kneecap off on the way down and the
other kneecap off on the way up
but it's that hard-nosed blue-collar
old-school rough-and-tumble football
that
the lions are going to be injecting into
the organization it comes from chris
spielman
rick spielman chris's brother said last
week on pftpm that when his wife saw the
dan campbell introductory press
conference
she said that's exactly the guy that
chris is gonna
was gonna hire he was destined to hire a
guy like that to be the head coach of
the team
that's the mindset so you know they're
going to go out and find some roughnecks
here right
right hey that 49ers team
in 2019 the way that defense played you
know we've talked about reduced
opportunities
to have live tackling and practice
reduced padded practices
reduced opportunities to get guys to the
point where they have that jim harbaugh
style
callus right where they can just go out
and do it so you find guys who are
wired to do it you find guys who will
run into a wall bounce off and laugh
yeah that's what they're going to be
looking for they're going to if they if
they know how to find these guys
they're going to have some bad asses on
that team that
uh across the board are going to be
rough and tough
and they may not bite off your kneecap
but but they definitely will try yeah i
agreed i would think that i mean that's
going to be the mantra of the football
team
it's going to be we're going to beat you
up physically dan campbell just came
from a team that
that's what they had too like you talk
about the 49ers in 2019
the saints are one of those teams too
you know i we always think about it as
drew brees and throwing the ball but
they're
they've been one of the most physical
teams in the nfl for the last five years
that they're fun to watch on film
because they try to kill people that's
what i respect about them so
yeah he's going to take that bill
parcells sean payton approach it seems
like
anthony lynn wants to run the football
play a physical brand of football as an
offensive coordinator and do that
it seems to be the way either way i'm
still surprised with gallaudet just
because
he is he is a you know he's a real
threat on the outside
you see the average yards per catch he's
a deep ball threat he's a great 50
50 guy and of course he can do some of
the underneath stuff too but he is a
real home run threat and that's where i
was a little surprised
that they didn't they didn't get it done
or franchising while together
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports